Rudy Guiliani now has confirmed that
he's joined Trump's legal team to
negotiate the end of a special counsel
bob mullahs probe good luck
Rudy apparently is looking to use his
personal relationship with Muller to
smooth things over okay well joining us
now is someone who also knows Bob Muller
former Attorney General Mike McKay Z who
held that position when Muller was FBI
director general meu KZ a judge meu KZ
got your on radio with me this morning
and now you're on TV with me and is like
we're spending the whole day together I
love it
that's me too that's great judge let's
talk about this wild day now we have a
criminal investigation going on at the
IG a criminal referral of Andrew McCabe
who was who was coerced commis deputy
but now the Inspector General is
investigating whether call me knew that
some of this information was classified
when he transmitted to his pal at
Columbia yeah I think we ought to put to
rest something that one of your guests
out of the last segment about how well
the memos weren't more classified at the
time they were classified as soon as he
wrote them I had an experience when I
started as AG of taking notes at a
meeting on it on a top-secret of
procedure and when I got up to leave the
meeting my then chief of staff leaned
over and wrote in big block letters at
the top t s / s CI meaning top secret
secure compartmentalized information in
other words those weren't my notes
those were the government's notes and
those weren't mr. commis memos they were
the government's memos and the
information in them if it was classified
was classified as soon as he put it down
on paper well judge he said they were
personal reflections and they were
personal thoughts and reflections on the
meeting that he had with the president
personal thoughts and reflections are
fine but if they are personal thoughts
and reflections about classified
information
then they are classified personal
thoughts and reflections and you can't
simply take him out and leak them judge
Mukasey you were Attorney General when
Bob Muller was FBI director and tell us
a little bit about him I know
you had daily briefs with him you met at
the White House with others with him on
a weekly basis at least what was he like
that's an excellent question the trouble
is I'm not much of a position to answer
it because although there were many
people that I met with less frequently
than I met with him
I really have very little in the way of
insight into what he's like as a person
I didn't get to see that you'll notice
that he always wears button-down white
shirts well he's very buttoned down and
buttoned up and it's very hard to get a
take on him as a person if he doesn't
want to give it to you and he apparently
didn't want to give it to me now did
when you had one-on-one conversations
with him did he seem like a you know
straight-up kind of guy like you know he
was he was because you were his boss I
mean people forget the Attorney General
is the boss of the FBI director we think
of the FBI director is an autonomous
person but you're his you were his boss
and then of course President Bush was
you know his ultimate boss yeah
nominally I was his boss there were
situations in which he performed
superbly I've in in helping to try to
convert the FBI from simply a crime
solving organization into an
intelligence gathering organization that
was a tough sell to a lot of people and
we had to put in place guidelines that
that I along with others at the
department drafted and gave to him and
he helped put them in place and did a
superb job at it however when there were
questions of some policy questions where
I questioned him about things that the
FBI was doing he pushed back and he was
somebody who was very devoted to
defending the interests of the bureau
there was a saying at the FBI I never
embarrassed the bureau and it's a
bureaucratic saying and they call it the
Federal Bureau of Investigation for a
good reason it's a bureaucracy and Alan
defended it so what are these disputes
about you know the way he was handling
certain types of investigations or I'm
not gonna get into this I'm not gonna
get into what it was about
but there was pushback and the interest
of defending what the FBI was doing who
was his deputy back then I can't
remember who it was who was it you can't
remember right I can't remember his
definite I was like it was obviously not
close it wasn't Andrew McCabe's I can no
it was not Andrew McCabe that I can tell
in judge as we close this out at the end
of this week where Jim Comey has been on
this book tour that seems like it's been
going on for months but it's only really
been going on for a few days do you
agree that the damage to the bureau is
somewhat significant given the fact that
he led this this agency and now he's you
know clearly strafing the president and
everyone close to him regrettably I
think the damage is enormous because the
head of the organization becomes the the
figurehead that everybody looks to to
judge how the organization performs and
his handling in particular everybody's
got their own favorite issue - with his
handling of the of the Clinton email
investigation was an outrageous
performance President Obama was sending
messages and receiving messages on
Hillary Clinton's private email server
Jim Comey knew that and when President
Clinton went on television and said
there's no issue here she doesn't really
intend to cause harm what he was saying
in essence is he better let her off
because if he wind up accusing her you
wind up accusing me and Comey followed
that lead and it's a the the notion that
this was somehow something that he had
to do for the welfare of the country is
a lot of disingenuous claptrap judge
Mukasey I love the word claptrap it's an
underused word and it's one of my
favorites so of course you use it judge
thank you so much